[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to season five of black Mira has
just dropped on Netflix and the new show
has a hell of a lot to unpack from it
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down striking Vipers starring Anthony
Mackie and giving my thoughts on the
meaning behind its ending this is full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't seen
the show yet and don't want anything
ruin for yourself then I highly
recommend that you turn off now with
that out the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video I
hope you enjoy it now sit back relax and
let's get into my ending explain
breakdown of striking vipers striking
vipers follows Danny a man that finds
himself bored how mundane that life has
become and is pulled to the wayside by
the temptation and online life tension
with this comes in the form of his
friend called who after buying him a
copy of the titular game reminds him of
the fun that they used to have together
the game is played in virtual reality
and due to the technology of it players
are able to feel all of the digital
highs and lows of every impact no matter
what kind there's a reference to Tucker
systems from Bandersnatch and the
episode has clear allusion to San
Junipero though personally I don't
believe that it matches up to the
caliber of that early on after diving
back into it Danny and Cole begin a
sexual relationship with one another in
the VR world and the two become fixated
on building a relationship together in
this at the cost of their real-world
connections who would have thought right
that the Marvel DC war would culminate
with Falcon hooking up with black man
there but I guess that's where are at
now I'm also sure mantas from guardians
of the galaxy is in this too
I don't know though for definite and
there's no way to instantly check if
this is correct or not
so we'll just assume that it is anyway
the game is a real call of Booty that
feels like it should be called striking
vipers xxx and it's definitely one of
the most sexually explicit episodes of
the show that is aimed towards the
hardcore players if
catch my drift after deciding to break
it off in order to focus on his marriage
we jump forward 7 months to find Danny's
wife heavily pregnant and see that his
life has returned to normality
juxtaposing this call is miserable and
clearly heartbroken over losing what
apparently was the best relationship he
ever had he is trapped in the mine state
that the real world simply does not live
up to the one that he created a line
which of course plays into society and
how many online relationships often
dissolved when brought into reality
unaware of their affair vo Danny's wife
invites call over one night to celebrate
Danny's birthday once more and his spark
seems to ignite between the two
temptation as always has reared its ugly
head in Danny's marriage and once more
the two reunite and have sex in the game
as their characters call confesses that
he loves Danny which puts the character
in a position where he makes the two
confront one another in the real world
to see if their connection exists
outside the game the two kiss but both
deny that they felt anything which
causes them to break up into a fight as
both realize that their connection was a
superficial one and this angers the pair
they get arrested and jailed because of
it and Danny's wife picks him up from
the prison and the character confesses
his affair which is when we fast-forward
a full year and discover the true
meaning behind ending in the final few
scenes we see that Danny's marriage
appears to be stable after the birth of
their child and that he and his wife
love each other more than ever as a gift
Danny's wife gives him a box containing
of the odd discs that will allow him to
return to the game and in return Danny
gives her a box for her wedding ring and
we see that she goes out to a bar
looking for a stranger to have a
one-night stand with it's clear that in
order to have a happy marriage the two
of had to make sacrifices that will
allow each other to live out their own
fantasies the two will get the best of
both worlds and within these rules that
they've constructed both have a degree
of freedom to me this episode highlights
how perhaps in the modern world modern
relationships must adapt to the fact
that temptation is more prevalent than
ever due to the Internet however we must
never let this subsidize a relationship
as reality never lives up to the fantasy
Danny and call discover this and though
I've seen many say that they are gay I
don't think the episode
that black and white both struggle not
only with their sexuality but also their
identity ensure that they are only able
to accept certain things when they're
disembodied or in another reality it is
their avatars that they find attraction
with and is metaphorically can apply to
things like profile pictures and online
images that have been edited and set up
in a certain way to appeal purely to
someone virtually the fact is that by
the end of the episode Danny and Karl
managed to separate the virtual from the
real and thus carry on with their life
outside of the game however there are a
lot of relationships that have fallen
apart due to temptation online and this
is as much an episode about accepting
the reality of the situation as it is
about indulging in the digital world
Coll represents those who live purely in
a digital reality and the shell lives
that they inevitably end up leading
because of it whereas Danny who has
connections in the real world is able to
still be happy outside the game there's
a lot of subtext to it and whilst I
found the episodes slightly plodding and
repetitive the message behind it is a
strong one however this still feels like
a dud and overall it pales in comparison
to San Junipero which dealt with similar
topics in a far more entertaining manner
I felt that the episode similar to the
game world was a bit two-dimensional
with none of the characters really
evolving all that much from how they
were in the beginning overall I feel
this episode is highly skippable and as
the first episode from the new season
that I watched it felt very
underwhelming I doubt I'll return to
this episode and either due to its
length or perhaps pacing it feels
slightly meandering and I scored it at a
6 out of 10 obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the episode and what
you took from it comment below and let
me know and if you enjoy this video then
please like it and make sure you stay
locked to the channel for more
breakdowns of the season coming later
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
take the time to watch this you've been
the best and I'll see you next time take
care
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]